this week on the dish of food writer
whose work has been described as the
equivalent to a Rubik's Cube's solution
to every kitchen puzzle imaginable
Nikki's segment has spent years
researching perfect flavor combinations
and wrote the best-selling flavor
thesaurus in 2010. her follow-up work
the flavor thesaurus more flavors is
published this month Charlie dagada
visited her London kitchen for a taste
of just how flavor works
Nikki segnet might just have the most
Discerning palette on the planet
in fact the New York Times calls the
award-winning author a culinary
Powerhouse oh my God yeah she's become a
global authority of flavor combinations
carving a career out of figuring out
what goes with what and what does not
and why okay I'm gonna try and taste it
in an order of strength so take a puzzle
Leaf my crash course starts with an easy
one tomato and basil if you've ever been
in a greenhouse or you've been in a
tomato patch in the high summer it
smells amazing so you get that really
intoxicating freshly picked freshly
grown smell and the basil does kind of
come along and do a bit of that you
can't eat the vine we move on to a
flavor combo a bit more complex this is
one of my favorite combinations dark
chocolate is the best way to show off
the beauty and charm of cardamom
the beauty and charm I love how you put
personality traits on food
yeah well if you work with them as long
as I do they become your friends
and now there are thousands of friends
friends found Bouncing Around the Globe
mixing ingredients from the markets in
the Middle East and the Far East to the
porticos and piazzas of Italy resulting
in flavor combos like spinach and
vanilla mint Never Lovelier than on a
date with a date and cranberry and
ginger which he describes as vaulting a
fruit-flavored Rainbow on a crystal
unicorn
it took more than three years for segnet
to research and write her first best
seller the flavor thesaurus in 2010
translated into 14 languages around the
globe it became a go-to reference book
for some of the most celebrated chefs in
the world building a following among
adventurous Foodies cheers
and tempting the uninitiated to try
concoctions like cumin flavored yogurt
that is a very powerful taste
and potato chips with pomegranate wow
it's interesting because it makes a
potato taste entirely different she's
Road tested every combination that made
the cut in the book and a lot that
didn't do you have to kiss a lot of
frogs oh you have to kiss a lot of frogs
and you have to try and pass off a lot
of really not very good things on your
husband and children
speaking of frogs one of her favorite
dishes came from a relationship gone bad
we were splitting up in this beautiful
fairy talish part of Italy and ended up
in a restaurant where this amazing
Italian woman brought out in a dish like
this this beautiful bubbling rigatoni
with artichokes and pancetta it's very
creamy it's got lots of cheese in it but
just to kind of punctuate all the
easiness of it are the bitter artichokes
it's a breakup meal it's break up now
she's fine-tuned the breakdown of the
biochemistry of how we taste keep your
nose pinched and chew it for a bit and
detect what you experience
you can probably taste it's a bit sweet
probably tastes it's quite sour
now you unpinch your nose
and that by unpinching your nose you let
the flavor in so the difference it
actually tastes like orange well you
could yeah exactly so you know what it
is because before that it could be sort
of anything that's slightly squelchy
that's sweet and sour yes so your taste
buds are doing that job the flavor is
really smell
segnit cooked up a range of dishes to
challenge our taste buds and our history
from a basil-free pesto so this is pesto
made of green beans cinnamon a little
bit of Parmesan and some cream
often if you have good basil it tastes
very much like cinnamon if you hadn't
told me I would have thought this was
just straight up basil right a maple and
fennel tart and chocolate and eggplant
or Melon Johnny a chicolato I mean this
is Italian it's from the south of Italy
it's the kind of thing that you might
have eaten before people divided things
into Savory corsets and desserts so
that's fried eggplant so it's thin
chocolate sauce it's yeah well I know
you put it like that it's a bit more
sophisticated obviously uh yeah it's
thin slices of eggplant then into flour
then into egg and then fried until
they're golden
what happens as a result of doing that
is they taste like pancakes like a 16th
century pancake with Nutella When you
mention eggplant I could taste eggplant
well that's why we don't tell the
children
that's one way to get them to eat their
vegetables yeah slather it in chocolate
that's a winner
that's amazing
it has been an education a sensual
Cornucopia before we finish one thing
has been bugging me growing up I was my
flavored pairings were sophisticated as
peanut butter and jelly where do you
stand on that I mean it's just so great
but you know
I have some issues with the Jelly that
some peanut butter is paired with like
strawberry it's just not right
strawberry doesn't have the doesn't have
the heft
doesn't have the aggressiveness there
will be Americans I know the United
States clutching their pearls right I
know I know you may have ruined peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches for me well
if there's one useful thing
and they say there is no accounting for
Taste but that's not the case in Nikki's
segnet's world for CBS Saturday morning
Charlie dagada London